[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're going to be exploring the
question has music become too disposable
yeah I mean with the yeah I I think
there's gonna be some looking backwards
to our experience with music listening
to music and how I mean what else eating
music we've well I still listen to it
but I do it so differently than I used
to oh yeah I mean it streams now and
streaming has changed everything in
terms of even how you view music and is
it is it devalued in my own mind because
of the how readily available it is via
streaming or is it not or is it not and
what have we gained well have we lost so
maybe we'll even look to the future
maybe we'll even look to the past well I
already said well yeah just try to make
that present in the past looking forward
to that discussion we do want to let you
know that starting with next week's
episode of ear biscuits the video
version is going to be available on
Sunday on the good mythical morning
channel not Saturday because what do we
got on Saturday now let's talk about
that yes it's a show new show it's a
shoe do show talk about that no we've
been we've done the shoe thing before
we're not yet doing it again right now
at least
nope so the new show the new Saturday
show let's talk about that on Saturdays
followed by the all-new video version of
your biscuits on Sundays every there's a
video if there's a freaking video every
day on the channel there is but right
now we're coming into your earholes
maybe your eyeholes - I mean it's your
prerogative but before we get into a
music thing it's it's been a while but I
haven't had an opportunity to give you
or you your biscuit ear just the
download of my experience at hanging out
with my friend Alicia Keys while my cuz
recorded his album and stayed at my home
and then the album was recorded at a
very rich man's private recording
facility and it was just it was a nutso
experience I mean are you at liberty to
speak of this I didn't I knew that well
there were people who showed up at this
recording studio and they had to sign
NDA's which stands for not this a-hole
no I did that's not what it stands for
it stands for non-disclosure agreement
now I nod yes did I sign an NDA the
answers not disabled that way you ended
up telling that joke yeah it was great
actually you know what in some weird way
I think that that was good I think that
setting it wasn't it wasn't a plan I'm
doing it as a throwback was even better
when I playing jokes it doesn't usually
go right I've observed that hey no I
mean I was agreeing with you yeah don't
not some dis a ho never said so yeah III
I'm free to talk about this there's not
there's not any problems here you're not
giving my boy Britain but my cousin
Britain Buchanan follow him on the stuff
well again I'm living vicariously
through in the wake of coming in second
on the voice where Alicia Keys was his
coach she really believes as do i and
and many tasteful purveyors of musical
talent that he's got what it takes man
he's a songwriter you know he had the a
whole bevy of songs and then he met with
Alicia in New York and they went through
and they picked out the ones they were
gonna do for his album and it's like a
very quick and dirty thing where it's
like over this week this weekend that
I'm referring to he went into the studio
can I tell you but can I just sit before
you record album
I you know I I told you this while you
were gone
yeah in Britain was in town Britain came
and had dinner with my family and just
just a side note because I also haven't
said this the reason Britain came into
town he was going to hang out with us
for the week and that's the weekend that
that's the week that my pop-up passed
away and I went home for the funeral and
I just want to say because I haven't
said it on here thank you all so much
for your outpouring of love and support
and encouragement that you've been
posting everywhere ever since we posted
that the dealing with imminent loss
episode of Eros gets so I just wanted to
say thank you for that and it was very
much a sense of closure going back home
for the funeral but bi-product was he
hate while he was here you were gone
yeah he was gone I was gone for the week
of it so he was kind of house-sitting
for me and waiting to record I got back
just in time to have the experience that
I'll tell you about and was we had him
over for dinner and I and I had my
sister-in-law and nieces thank you for
that by the way and I was glad to you
know but it it was it was mostly like
okay this guy is he's in Los Angeles he
he doesn't know anybody right he's links
cousin he's you know a mile away from my
house I should have him over for dinner
you had you had a deep sense of
obligation but let me tell you a little
something which I already told you this
I mean I texted you and Christy this yes
I think he just texted her actually no
and she told me no okay you weren't very
responsive while you were traveling
which is okay I mean I did I'm not gonna
hold what did you say no I said that
Britain is our new favorite person I
mean like yeah he is an incredible guy
he's like pre-cooling I mean it's not
just that he's cool
I mean he's genuine he's not really not
cool in the right way that you shouldn't
be cool yeah I got too cool for schools
not 18 years old it's the fact that he's
18 years old and he's so first of all
he's woke he's woke I don't like to use
the word but he's incredibly woke you
all right I was incredibly observant I
mean I bet you made some false
assumptions being that he's from this
podunk he's from Sanford no I didn't
make any assumptions at all I just gotta
say podunk cuz my dad lives I came in
with no expectations at all but I
definitely did not come in expecting him
to be because I remember being 18 years
old I remember the way that I thought
about things at 18 years old and or lack
of thought about in the way that I
engage with other adults who are not 18
years old
right and this guy is he's something
special now well I don't think he
considers you an adult let's just put
that aside the fact that he is
incredibly talented incredible voice
great songwriter all those things which
are true and you'll get into that he's a
really good good guy in fact we soak he
talked about so many things we stayed
over into our house until it was like
11:30 at night and and then he leaves
and the first thing that my oldest son
Locke says it's like this is a 14 year
old 14 year olds don't issue these kinds
of things yeah he walks out the door the
door closes and he's like that is a
great guy he's just like a genuinely
great guy he should have won I mean how
did all the greatness get on that side
of the family that is awesome my sided
fan so if you're trying to cut on me it
actually became a compliment so they go
there's that part of the family tree
just that branch I mean it's very
concentrated did any of the Grimm here
maybe my Brandt he's a great guy not
dead okay I won't do that again
because he didn't win he's got a little
bit more freedom to then cut this album
work with Alicia on it and I was like oh
I don't get to me I of course I wanna I
want to go with you to this studio I
want to see what it's like I love
watching music documentaries I love
talking about the type of music stuff
we're gonna talk about today I just love
being on a fly on the wall in that world
that's why those documentaries are so
much fun for me to watch but being there
in a recording studio environment for
the first time that was like legit was
amazing and it
turns out that this was like everyone
there was in awe of this place that we
ended up going and I'm like at some
point I'll get to meet Alicia which
would be freaking awesome right cuz she
seems like an amazing person
right and Britain said that she was it
was and let me I got a I got a read
about him here a little bit to give this
stuff straight but they somehow worked
it out to get an invitation to record
his album at Paul Allen's house Paul
Allen is the co-founder of Microsoft
along with Bill Gates he has a little
bit of money according to his wiki he is
the 43rd richest person in the world
only forty third net worth 25 billion he
also owns the 14th biggest yacht on the
planet how big is that huh it's 95 feet
414 feet it's called octopus okay my
yacht knowledge is incredibly as of 2013
it is the 14th in the list of motor
yachts by length good gracious it is
equipped with two helicopters a
submarine a swimming pool a music studio
a spare helicopter has a spare hello in
observe basketball court he's got a
helicopter to get to the helicopter
that's how big the yacht is 400 feet we
gotta take a yeah he's gotta take my
copter from one into the yacht to the
other end to get on the other helicopter
cuz that gas is burned out didn't go to
like an Islanders alright I will say
that did not meet this man he was not
there of course he was but there were
keepers of the place their full-time
jobs were just to keep the place the
first one was a security guard who
grilled me before I was allowed through
the gate okay and I get inside I'm a
little self-conscious because I just
feel like a hanger-on you know it's like
oh there's an artist and there's like
you know what she was cousin I'm the
cousin slash chauffer slash like guy
whose house he's staying and everybody
brings their cousin everybody to the
recording session it's my cousin by the
way the octopus yacht was not parked
outside of his mansion which the
recording studio was
this huge building and then up the hill
from it was the rest of his mansion like
multiple buildings and it was rock
Hudson's mansion
oh so Marilyn Monroe swimming around in
rock Hudson's pool there's probably
pictures of that everywhere at least
that's what Chris the keeper of the
studio told me hmm
I mean you go outside of the studio and
it's like it looks like a resort but
it's just this private home and I look
around the corner I'm like snooping
around cuz I'm not doing any here you're
not in any danger and I look up the hill
at the mansion and then lo and behold
there's a there's a big thing coming
down the hill there's a like a whatsit
it's on a track and it's like a like I
want to know like it's like a gondola
except it's on a track attracts like
gondola it's like an elevator huge train
elevator that connects the studio to his
house that's freaking crazy man so what
happens when you the studio looking for
ways to spin the studio itself was over
ten years old it all looks brand-new
and it's a three-story building that the
whole facade overlooking Beverly Hills
is just glass walls and only you can
find footage of it by searching for u2's
live performance of Songs of Innocence I
think their latest album if you search
that on YouTube there's some live
performances that they recorded in this
studio mm-hmm they recorded a lot of
that album there there was you go into
the booth well you go into the engineer
console whatever that thing's called and
there's uh there's a big sign thing that
has everybody from u2 signed it
there's he's got memorabilia hanging
everywhere cuz Paul Allen's a huge rock
and roll nut he's he's there like a big
Jimi Hendrix fan
he owns he's got a warehouse Britten
told me that they told him a warehouse
full of like all the guitars he's
collected if you can name like a really
famous good
he probably owns it and just has it in a
warehouse including the guitar that Jimi
Hendrix said on fire you know on stage
so anyway I go in this place is um it's
just it's state-of-the-art amazing cuz
he just threw so much money at this
thing and then all these vintage guitars
they're just bringing out for the band
to play that he just has there I'm
really self-conscious I meet the first
guy he comes around he says hey how are
you today I'm like I'm great he says hey
grant nice to meet you and I'm like oh I
was like actually I just said I'm great
heretofore known as grant but my name is
link and he's like I'm Chris nice to
meet you I've already screwed yeah yeah
you never recover we tried to be really
quiet and not say a lot that's great
this hang out trance the quiet one the
cousin but the but the place was just
crazy and then finally a weather I mean
there was three different days that I
took him there and I was hanging out you
know over that over that weekend and the
second day Alysha shows up in the middle
of him recording and you know she's
she's simultaneously stunning just I
mean she's she's beautiful
and then she exudes she's got this like
this she's got more positivity than
anybody I've ever experienced the way it
just like radiates off of her more than
me more even even more than you right
it's great it's great to have an idea of
a celebrity and then meet them and it
and it just it just delivers right you
know she delivered like like nine months
of pregnancy BAM the bar is really high
and she just floats right over it yeah
I'm a big fan now she's great super nice
he likes grant Shelia he's a big fan of
grass
I met her husband Swizz Beatz whis be
famous rap producer heard the name jay-z
DMX you met Johnny and DMX no he
produced say whoa songs and I already
got crazy
winning Grammys and whatnot super cool
guy we talked about eating hot peppers I
gave a little plug to our channel oh man
but then instead of us beats us instead
of going to our Channel
he put up his phone he started searching
I thought he's gonna go to my channel
it's like I'm gonna feel awkward but I'm
secretly gonna be happy that he's
watching my stuff but instead he pulled
up those freaking Hot Chip videos like
like the ones we didn't do you know yeah
I was like I eat a whole hot pepper
Swizz Beatz can you please look at my
channels like but grant did you eat a
chip you did not I'm not interested
Medus met their kids Egypt in Genesis
Wow
yeah throwback and I'm uh I'm I'm bored
a little bit later I'm scrolling on
reddit you know cuz I'm trying to stay
out of the way what am I gonna do I'm
gonna thumb through reddit and Egypt
who's like I don't know 9 or 10 sits
down next to me and starts scrolling my
phone for me of course he does admit
he's like I don't know how but he's like
a pickpocket next thing I knew he had my
phone and he's watching all of like a
montage of all of the deaths in Jurassic
Park oh and I'm like and I look at him
like as if to say how did you get my
phone
I was I was literally on it and you have
it and he looked at me and uh he kind of
went back to I was like uh I can't see
and then he like turned it and for the
next 15 minutes we watched all the
deaths in Jurassic Park to you and Egypt
had a moment yeah and then five hours
later when we leave the recording studio
Britain and I are driving home and you
know my phone at at like a poignant
point in our debrief conversation
connected via bluetooth to my speakers
in my computer I mean in my car
and it just started playing the audio of
all of the deaths from Jurassic Park
which is like that's a little
distracting to drive it was kind of it
was a good button on the end of an
amazing experience of being a fly on the
wall of watching amazing musicians
collaborate with Britain to make this
album in record time it was the band
from The Voice they had just listened to
the demo versions of the songs and then
they would come in and Britain would
play it live once and then they would be
like alright let's go
it was amazing how great they are there
and the best in the world they play
thousands of songs live because of the
being on the voice for all these years
and it was super cool to just be sitting
it sitting in the control booth just
watching them through there's like
panoramic view of this glassed-in thing
that's probably unmatched by any other
studio except the one on the same guys
yacht so I mean it's it's it's it was
just crazy to be along for the ride and
then to cap it off with hearing every
person scream bloody murder death at the
hands of Raptors and other dinos and so
we don't know exactly when when this
album is coming out but I mean sometime
in the fall hopefully they recorded all
the all all the music tracks but then
he's gonna go to Alicia's studio in New
York and track his vocals because they
didn't have time for that maybe I can go
up there and lay down some tracks no
just just watch silently backup vocals
by Grant and Alicia so that's how I'm
enjoying music now you know I mean my
new standard is I've got to be in the
room with with the masters of their
craft and when you're not doing that
you're enjoying music digitally mostly
as I do we used to enjoy it
analogue Ollie don't talk about I talk
all about that but first we want to let
you know that you can get the all-new
ear biscuits t-shirt look at this dang
look at it I like the I like the lined
nature
that's me that's you that's your
biscuits
that's the show that is happening right
now
I like the black with the white on it
it's kind of got a roadie vibe if you
want to feel like you're on a fly on the
wall of this recording experience wrap
it with that shirt
mythical dots store other stuff too okay
so III think I do think about this
question a lot what because the way we
listen to music has changed so much what
what is it how has it changed my
relationship with music has it devalued
what music is to me I mean do do our
kids view music differently than we did
because they're starting from a place of
having arguably free four in their
experience access to any and everything
at any moment they want it anywhere they
are via phones and streaming you know I
think and I I guess I get I get
concerned but maybe I should just be
nostalgic maybe there's just as good as
bad I'm just raising all the questions
well let's let's start why don't we
we're just talking about when we were
kids the experience with the way that we
would experience new music and this is
gonna be true for many of you who are
listening because many of you like us
have kind of lived through this digital
revolution and I think sometimes we we
underestimate because you forget you so
quickly
just leave it I think about like
literally like two or three years ago
yeah before I finally like went in and
paid for music streaming because I was
still just buying albums you know things
change so quickly but if you go all the
way back to the beginning like do you
remember well cuz even before you go
back yeah because even even just like my
not Apple
music but I had this Apple Apple match
subscription and that's when you pay
Apple came out with this thing and it
still exists but my subscription was up
and I'm like ain't paying for this but a
year ago I'm like something you know me
I would never pay for anything and I
actually paid to have Apple match
everything that I already owned in their
cloud and there were there was a handful
of things they didn't already have in
their cloud that I owned that as a part
of the match process was uploaded to
their servers and kept I'm talking like
demo demo recordings and stuff like that
which is now occurring to me I may have
lost but in general what was it was the
fact that I'm now like a year later I'm
like why why would I want to keep my
music in a cloud when I have access via
streaming to all music everywhere but
and and again that was just a year ago
right that I was paying for that well
but like you said if you go all the way
back yeah so you know we tell the story
often about the you know the first time
we bought our own music
I want to go back even before that okay
to the very first time I consumed music
kind of on my own and and for me that
was with a record player in my bedroom a
record a record player so before because
I remember getting my first you know we
called it a jam box yeah boom box is
usually what they prefer to as but and
then we would get the ones that had like
two cassette players and the record
player on top but I'm talking before
that it was just a record player and my
collection of music was just my parents
old records and it was I remember some
very specific things like the Four
Seasons like Frankie Valli and the Four
Seasons mm-hmm
Chuck Berry Elvis Presley I mean there
was only there was about 12 albums that
they had just for some reason ended up
in my room so I would listen to those
same albums over and over again and then
there was also what is the this the
smaller record is at 45 is that what it
is yeah and you have to change the speed
for that right
was the official song like theme song of
the Georgia Bulldogs and the the center
the center sticker on the record had
like a Georgia Bulldog agha they called
it I don't even remember the song at
this point but I'm sure that it still
it's not the fight song it's like this
Bulldogs song and I just and that was it
I just played that stuff over and over
again
and of course listen to the radio but
that was the first time that I took
albums and listened to him and I would
put those albums on and pick something
up in my room and lip-sync it and walk
around the room singing you know and out
sometimes I would like slick my hair
look full Elvis and do it yeah and this
is this was just an experience that I
was having
I myself I had a similar experience we
had in the house with Jimmy we had a
that guest room in the front that heaven
and eventually had the Nintendo well it
had it had a record player and like the
two tower speakers like most houses had
the room where you had that or if you
got even older like my Nana Papa they
had like the big piece of furniture that
had the record player in it and the
speakers coming out the front which he
didn't buy about like vintage stores now
big hulking piece of furniture but my
mom had a record like a little 45 single
of the name game the name game banana
fanna fo fanna feet mom Anna Anna I
would play that and I would dance around
and we had the pac-man theme song get a
lot of mileage out of that yeah we had
that and we had Freddy feel good let's
see what race Stevens
Oh race T yeah country music comedy
music guy which is kind of crazy that
one of the first things I listened to
was a comedy a musical comedy record
from Ray Stevenson my Paris look
Fredi feel good it actually wasn't that
funny but it he he played all the
instruments of the but Freddy feelgood's
band with his mouth he was like Bobby
McFerrin and you know what I still have
those records hmm I have him in the
console at the house right now and I
played him for the kids I thought it was
crazy because once I got a record player
you know for my birthday and I'm like
teaching Lando how to play it but yeah
you would you would listen to the record
and I'm reminded now that I finally have
a record player now that it's it's it's
almost a it's a focused experience you
put this disc on there and then it plays
for a certain amount of time and you
kind of have to be there for it because
the speakers are only there
you can't walk walk anywhere you want
and then you would flip it over and you
would listen to the other side and while
you're doing that I mean you think about
how intimately familiar you were with
not only the music itself but the device
I mean the actual medium the record
itself and then the sleeve I you know I
would sit there and the album cover
itself I would hold it and I remember
seeing that Four Seasons Four Seasons
album of course they dressed they all
wore the same exact thing you notice new
things because you've we've looked at
you've done this under stress there and
looked at it made observations about
like look at how Frankie Valli's like
sitting over there he's like obviously a
little bit different they're all
together but he's kind of out in front
and a little bit to the side and you
just made observations about their hair
and their clothes and then you read
everything on the back it was just a
totally different relationship and then
it was like I said for me it wasn't this
endless supply of records that was it
and it wasn't being added to it was like
we just had that handful of records that
I listen to all the time and it was
either that or the radio until I was
given the opportunity to buy my first
album but it was just a familiarity
which was a tape right which was a
cassette yeah it was a cassette it was
weird out in 3d yeah mine was um
weird al' even worse I you know I didn't
I didn't buy music until your mom it
like your mom had more music available
than my parents did I think
yeah because I don't remember they were
by Lionel Richie Michael Jackson Al
Green that's what like my mom got me
into she had those records but as far as
tapes the second tape I bought was the
fat voice and the brother had the Fat
Boys if my brother had it it was
technically available to be listened to
and that's the other part of it music
was so much about if you had that
physical thing and if or if somebody
gave it to you or if your brother had it
you know I mean getting into rap music
was because your brother was into it and
his friends so Cole and Oliver would
listen to rap music on their tapes and
when I come over to your house I knew
you had tapes but if your brother had
the tape it automatically became more
cool so but like I remember I would go
in his room and I'd like see oh he's got
he's got kool Moe Dee kool Moe Dee
statically remember being introduced to
kool Moe Dee
he's got EPMD yeah he's got NWA you know
yeah I mean the funny thing is is that
you got these and this this is something
not calm this is true this was true all
over the nation but you got these little
redneck white boys in middle of nowhere
in North Carolina who are buying NWA
having no idea what any of this is about
but just being absolutely man it was a
movie it wasn't it was like oh you've
got the thing I mean if it was an
illicit object that you would you would
insert it into a thing and then music
would come out you know it wasn't it
wasn't something that just there was
contraband your pocket it was everywhere
it was contraband yeah it was secret and
it was you could touch it and you could
flow it and you could feel guilty I mean
you remember Jeremy Fisher who lived
down the street yeah because there was
so much profanity in this rendus and his
music and our parents were upset that we
were listening to it but they never
really heard it directly because you
knew when they were coming up the stairs
to cut it off what he did he was
well I've got a solution he was like you
take a couple of pieces of toilet paper
and you put it into the top years and
you won't hear you put it into the top
of the cassette and wait until it gets
to that point on the tape where there's
a curse word hit pause and then hit
record and they hit unpause and go Boop
and he would literally record his own
beeps over the curse words he was the
neighborhood sync which made NWA very
difficult to listen to a little bit
distracting because everything would
drop out except Jeremy Fisher's beep and
he provided this as a service he was
like I'll take your tape and do that for
a night that happened one time and I
never let it happen again talk about a
dead career path but the other thing I
remember from that era was the way that
the process of being introduced to to
new music from someone else was hey
listen to this I remember being over it
the hetrick house uh-huh and you know
mark was like a year older than Paul was
I think Cole's age yeah so a few years
older and we sat down and pause bedroom
and he was like have you guys heard
Metallica oh snap and I was like what's
Metallica and I'd been listening to you
know when I wasn't listening to Bali I
was listening to weird out so the
transition into Matata and I'd done
something a little bit of rap but this
is actually but probably before Cole got
into rap he turns on he had like a big
stereo like the speakers were separate
it wasn't all one thing and he I'm
sitting on the bed and he turns on I
don't even remember what song it was
Matt's I just remember thinking this is
amazing and probably evil you know it
was like so it was aggressive it made me
think that it made me think differently
about Paul Hetrick I just remember
thinking this guy he must be into some
weird stuff because my point of
reference but I just remember thinking
it wasn't like I mean just the other day
I had somebody send me an album by just
sending me a link on my phone and
it was just like I'll get to that when I
want to no no that wasn't how it worked
back then it was like come into my
bedroom sit down like intersting I'm
going to control the volume I'm going to
look at you as you're experiencing this
I'm gonna check in with you and see how
you're processing this and it's this
moment that I remember in a way that I
just questioned whether or not you have
the ability to have that level of
experience when somebody just sends you
a link to a song I mean you know why
artists have listening parties you know
they work so hard to make this thing and
you want to have this communal
experience of except just listening to
it this is different from a concert you
know it's like and you ain't you I do
feel like we used to have I mean yeah
the thing about discovery it was coming
to my room I'm gonna play it for you or
I'm gonna get I'm gonna loan you this
object you're gonna do it dub it and
then give it back to me and while you're
listening to it I can't listen to it
unless it comes on the radio or you go
to the store and you buy it and for me
as a kid every weekend my mom would go
shopping but I didn't have money to buy
a cassette every weekend but it was a
very strategic thing like I had to
decide okay Rhett has the MC Hammer
album you know what was it called it was
the one before too legit to quit was the
no no no please hammer don't hurt him
please hammer don't hurt him which was
before that you can't touch this album
but Cole has this other guy young MC I
think you can't touch what was on Noah
did you have did you have young MC yes
Cole had it and then you had MC Hammer
and I felt like Who am I gonna side with
cuz I can only buy one tape this month
basically or am I gonna buy something
that's a little a little more out there
that nobody has so that I can like a say
hey I got something nobody's got and
it's actually good you know so you know
at the time you had a sense it was an
investment mentality cuz you want you
know you got eight
twelve bucks you want to spin on an
album you can't listen to it ahead of
time there were a few places eventually
where you could like listen to CDs in
the store and use like dirty old
headphones that everybody's been putting
on but for us it was like you look at
the cover of the cassette and you're
like alright Cole's got an EP MD tape
but this is that they got a new one
coming out I'm gonna be the first to get
that one I got it like obviously there
was no internet but we didn't it was
word of mouth because we didn't describe
to any magazines that had any of this
information no it was just somebody at
school would tell somebody else and
somebody somewhere had a magazine
there's no I know that I I mean I would
just go in and look at at the record bar
I will look at the cassette section and
you would see the rap section I would
buy I would buy something what you would
go to the ones where they had the most
of that tape - yeah you know I'm saying
so if they had like 30 young MC tapes
you a knew that must be oh yeah this is
a demand a new one I got to get this one
and then that would be the tape that you
would listen to and it so it was it it
was a deep experience that is very
difficult to it to achieve but it was it
was almost the whole system was built
for a deep experience before now you
have to have one in spite of the system
I'll get to that but in other words I'd
make a calculated decision out of all
the tapes that I can buy this month this
is the one I'm gonna buy and it's the
one that I'm just gonna listen to again
and again I'm gonna put the tape in and
I'm gonna play it and I didn't have one
you know I didn't have a newfangled you
hit fast forward the special fast for a
button that can detect when there's a
gap in the audio and that's the next
song you just listen to it and it and it
was an album experience half by half
just like a record we had to flip that
tape over and you would just sit there
and you would experience it in a certain
order that the artist intended on both
sides and then you would do it again and
and you would sit there and you you know
unfold that those liner notes and you
would read the lyrics
and you read what's what who they were
sampling I remember you know when I got
a Tribe Called Quest low in theory one
of the you know one of the greatest rap
albums of the 90s easily I got that
because Cole had the previous one it's a
long title I'm not gonna say it here I
can't quite remember people's
instinctive travels in the paths of
rhythm but I would listen to the low in
theory okay who are they they're
sampling stuff I didn't even know that
what sampling was right you read about
it in a line around severance white band
what is that and then I'm like looking
through my mom's a record collection
again and I realize she's got average
white band records and I started
bringing those into my room and
listening to those and I'm like this
kind of sucks to me because it doesn't
sound anything like the rap but somehow
they found something in this except to
make pick up the pieces pick up the
pieces oh yeah that was immediately okay
that's one of the best instrumentals I
think it's all great now but it was like
it was a treasure hunt experience to
connect dots of how of their creative
process it was like my mom has this
album that these guys in New York turned
into this new thing that
Rhett's older brother thinks is cool you
know yeah and I'm sitting here in my
room by myself reading it just pouring
over and that was the experience it was
a it was a forced paced deep experience
that everything now is geared towards
the opposite of that yeah well yeah
listen listen okay
so at risk of sounding like a couple of
old farts who are reminiscing about how
great it was when we were introduced to
music and you had to like all the songs
I'm sorry but you yeah but you you it
doesn't it didn't it's listening I would
just I you'd listen to that you you know
the songs that sucked because you'd
listen to those too right well I because
you had invested in it yeah because
you've been
honey in times like I've got to get
through this because it makes it feel
like it's worth it now let's contrast
this with the way things are today and
I'm not going to as I talk about this
I'm actually going to talk about the I'm
not judging the experience because I
think there's actually something to the
way things are done now yeah okay so the
way that I introduced myself first of
all I subscribe to I kind of died
right now I have Apple music that's just
because I have an iPhone and so I end up
doing a lot of Apple things so that's
kind of my streaming service that I use
but what I'll do in order to find new
music is in fact the other night I did
this sitting there and I'm like I want
to find something I want to find some
like melancholy Americana like first of
all just the fact that I can think that
yeah and not have to go to the smallest
section at Sam Ash there was never a
section at Sam Goody's there's a bunch
of Sam if I had had gone in melancholy
what melancholy Americana they would
have been like sir please leave but now
I have the ability to to to go basically
to be like americana section and then
it's like latest releases and I can do
like you know top tracks or latest
releases and what I'll do is I'll play
one and I make a decision sometimes two
seconds in sometimes 15 seconds in as to
whether or not this is I'm gonna
continue listening and I'll go through
10 11 12 different people most of them I
haven't heard of and then I'll land on
somebody and I'll be like Oh something
that grips you in like track 1 so like
for instance I did this and the album
art does still play into that though
right oh yeah yeah you can look at the
album art and make the combination of
the album art and the title of the album
you kind of make a decision right does
this person try I believe me to give me
something that is gonna work for me
so I just recently discovered and I see
and I'd heard of this band
and the milk carton kids okay like it's
one of those like oh yeah I don't know
anything about those guys but I but I've
heard they've been out for a while
they've gotten multiple albums but when
I was doing my melancholy Americana deep
dive you know 10 12 albums into top
tracks or latest releases whatever I get
to milk carton kids and then I might mom
okay and I stuck with it and I ended up
listening to the entire album and now I
consider myself a fan of these guys who
by the way are based in Eagle Rock close
by are they missing or what's their
story I think it's a play on that okay
but that's a complete melancholy but
think about the how many people I passed
by for different reasons before I landed
on these guys and here's the thing is
that because I could do that again
tonight with any other combination of
musical descriptors and then I could do
it again the next night never repeating
the rabbit-hole that I'm gonna go down
don't have to go back to melancholy
Americana I'm a naughty I may not go
back to those guys now I actually used
my recently added quite a bit because
it's oh yeah you remember those guys
milk carton kids you found the other
night listen to those guys again but
that there's something to that that
there's negative and there's positive
yeah yeah there's a tremendous positive
that you can that the mechanism for
discovery and it's I mean as an artist
or I'm kind of projecting onto more of
you know music artists here that I have
to think that the rate of evolution of
sound and of uh of music has increased
dramatically because of of access I mean
it's is it's the same thing as just our
access to information with the internet
has drastically accelerated so many
aspects of society right you know I
think III believe that that hip-hop is
still one of the fastest shifting genres
I don't know why but I just observed it
I think it is I could be
about that but I think that has to do
with being able to hear so much like
artists being able to hear and be
inspired by so many different people at
any in any one sitting so to speak well
I think you know that's pretty cool
there's a value it's so easy to
accidentally bite somebody and hip up
and in for your flow to sound exactly
like somebody else yeah I think you're
kind of costly kind of moving away from
that and trying to set some sort of
target where if you if you're doing
melancholy and Kali americana and you
know he sounds a little bit like
so-and-so it's like that's a good thing
but if it's like uh he sounds like Drake
you're like that's that's not good
he needs to change needs to innovate in
some way
but when I think okay so I think about
my kids in the way that you know you
mentioned you mentioned Tribe Called
Quest so the other day we were on a road
trip and I've done this I've done a
couple of these things where I'm like I
started thinking back on some music that
I got introduced to and I'm like I'm
going to listen to this and I'm gonna
tell my kids what I was thinking and how
I first heard this and that kind of
thing and we kind of go through yeah and
so Locke is uh he's really in the
hip-hop and he listens to you know like
when what's-his-name extension I don't
know how you say the guy's name that
died recently that was a you know triple
extension I probably saying it wrong I
don't that's how out of the loop I am
extension cord but he was like like when
he that dude died like it was like it
was difficult for life for a couple of
days and of course he was like all into
the theory about how Drake was faulted
and all this but so he was pretty well
acquainted with like you know the
cutting edge loaf I even some low five
stuff which I really which I'll get back
to that a second but so I was like okay
I'm gonna play you some 90s hip-hop I
ended up going through Tribe Called
Quest black sheep I started just
thinking of some stuff that was
performed at the talent show you
third base and I know I'm jumping I'm
jumping all over the place would like
how this is hold held up Tribe Called
Quest has held up black sheep hasn't
held up quite as much yeah
third base doesn't hold up at all like
are you listening to third base now and
you're like I think there's some I think
there's a couple but I think some I
think it holds up but not like it feels
like he's me he's like getting off
rhythm oh you know like okay but what
did what nice is awful it's all wrinkled
but it like think about it oh then we
got to the Fugees and like okay well you
made it okay yeah yeah so I mean I'm
jumping and jumping all around the 90s
but there's this like okay I can see
like some of it is some of its good but
then I can start feeling some of it not
really working it seems a little bit
right I mean I tried young MC at one
point and I was I can't I can't believe
handy how bad was this horrible but I
mean I think Fugees I hope you thought
that was no he thought it was great and
it's less about what he thought about it
he appreciated it he thought some of it
was good but it was more how easily I
could just think of something and
introduce him to it and I was like yeah
getting into the question of is this
disposable it's like this is not the
same thing as if I gave him an album and
he had a machine in his room and he had
to take the thing and put it into the
thing it's been some time with it
there's no cost so I'm witty without
doubt an individual album or an
individual song has become more
disposable but at the same time as a
family we do things that my family never
did we play music yeah all the time
yeah like when I go home tonight music
will be playing in my house we dinner
half the time music is playing wake up
in the morning
music is playing we've got a computer
and an Alexa in the in the kitchen and
so yeah we do the same thing it's just
it's and you know I saw musics always
playing I came into the kitchen the past
two a few days and the Beatles have been
playing and you know I I don't play the
Beatles but I mean of course I love the
Beatles you have to but it's Lily who's
somehow has gotten into the Beatles she
went to a girls Rock summer camp with a
friend of hers and they got her into the
Beatles and but also like the White
Stripes and so it's you know you she's
found people that she thought was cool
that liked cool stuff and now she's
she's liking that she's starting to you
know to be exposed to things like the
Beatles and it's just it's easy it's
just around I mean the so there's such a
the deep experience we had is now the
wide experience that our kids have you
know the the widest and experience got
for us back in the day was you remember
this the BMG music service they would
and also Columbia house it would be
eight CDs for one cent or it would be an
ad for 12 CDs for the price of one and
what you would do is they would send you
this big um like envelope and you would
open that up and it would have it would
have a sheet hundreds of it would have a
sheet with like 12 blocks 12 empty
blanks and then the the one that you'd
pay for and it would be stamps like
lickable stickers of albums
oh that's had one that was a checkmark
it was like ordering sushi the one yeah
there were all different kinds and it
was very like again it was part of the
ordering process was like the whole time
tile tactile if it was a catalog a
figure this a lot of them looked like
music magazines where they would like
Columbia House would they would have
articles with like weird factoids about
crap in them to make you think that
you're reading like a rolling stone type
ripoff yeah but then you would select
the album and you would you would order
30
in CDs this was the agency and it wasn't
easy to figure out which they wanted
because as people who had bought one
album at a time maybe to on a really
good entertaining so how do you get to
13 I'm throwing ac/dc in there yes it's
you know back in black which I'm really
glad I did that I mean Bob I I first
heard Bob Marley because you put that in
here 12 yeah I did and it was and it was
like okay I was on a classic rock kick
and so it was this like I just went
through greatest hit classic rocks
Greatest Hits
section and I took those stamps off so
like cream and Eric Clapton the Eagles
everybody's got to get that Eagles
greatest hits album right now you learn
how to play guitar Tom Petty and the
Heartbreakers Greatest Hits with Mary
Jane's last dance on there and things
change
I was listening that talked about us and
now that is a good the relationship and
then they ship you 12 CDs at once
CDs changed the relationship with music
because now not only it was still
tactile it was still an experience of
owning something you can but get brown
you but and I wasn't totally right about
that you can skip easily so it made it a
little bit easier to dispose of but it
also was a little bit precious because
especially if you are like me I'm
assuming that you didn't do this as
often as I did you leave the CD out
scratch it man yes yes I think I
probably speak for alot of people out
there and that many of your CDs now you
think I'm bad I remember when I first
got to know Jessi and she would put one
of her CDs in her car I mean it was like
looking at like when you got the light
just right on her CD so you could see
all the scratches it was like she let a
cat get on this like she has put she has
let a cat work its feelings out on the
surface of this yeah and you're
listening to hit me baby one more time
and it's only just hit me and that
happened so funny thing is I have an
artifact of this time of my life on that
album on back in black on back in black
the actual song back in black yeah
somehow when I transferred all my CDs
over to my computer years ago and then
they were matched on iTunes I thought it
was supposed to like repair if you had
some issues yeah it is something
happened with back in black and it still
has all the skipping from that CD intact
what if you accidentally over wrote the
master in the envy cloud I don't think
that's like you ruined back in black for
everybody for perpetuity well first of
all I apologize if that's the case just
a side note I got this when I was
thinking about BMG I was thinking how do
they make money and it's I like did some
searching about it didn't cancel it if
you didn't here's what they did
they would give you the 13 CDs he only
bought one but then every maybe it was
every month or every few weeks they
would send you it's kind of like Netflix
they would send you another CD in the
same genre that you picked for me
classic rock and they would charge you
for it until you wrote basically wrote
them and told them that you're canceling
and so they would charge you all they
made it overpriced I mean I'm very
difficult to cancel yeah and I found
when I was when I was looking for that I
found this documentary that I'm gonna
watch so I'm recommending something I
haven't watched except the beginning of
and it was a guy filmmaker Chris will
czy in 1994 the first thing that he did
was he got a he got a job Brett after he
graduated he got a job working at
Columbia House so in the in the place
and he took his video camera to work
everyday and documented his process of
working at Columbia House in 1994 and
it's called the target shoots first I
mean this guy went on to produce a lot
of other things including the the
television version of this American Life
when that was on Showtime so yeah he's
he's like doing lots of good stuff now
but that was like the first pet project
you know I'll I'll tweet out the link to
the video of that like our 20-minute
documentary that he made of his like
it's almost like found
or just like very intimate footage cuz I
kind of skipped through it of his like
taking his camcorder to work everyday
and it's just like a snapshot of what
the music industry was like well and
Columbia House is such a weird thing
right a weird moment
now another thing but the experience was
that's as wide as it got and now it's
infinite and so here's another just
anecdote about the way things work and
just not too long ago by the time you
hear this it will have been a few weeks
I'm sure but I was doing some writing
the other day on one of the projects
that were working on and I I like to
listen to instrumental instrumentals you
know instrumental music when I write
because I don't like to be manipulated I
also like to I don't like to listen to
words because I immediately I'm writing
words and an Elsa and I started
listening to words and and also don't
want music that has too much of an
emotional quality because I feel like it
will influence when I'm writing so I
like things that are a little bit you
know non-committal and so I tweeted this
out shout out to red MC on Twitter if
you follow me you know that I tweeted
this if you don't follow me you don't
know that's your loss I tweeted does
anybody have any recommendations for
instrumental music for writing and I
kind of qualified it with I don't want
it to be too emotional whatever thank
you for all your suggestions
someone actually multiple people said
[Music]
loaf I just search lo-fi hip-hop 24/7
just Google that okay and if you do that
a YouTube channel from chill hop music
comes up and it's just a live stream
there is a looped animated video of I
think now it's like a raccoon in bed
like studying or something it's like a
it's like a character like sitting there
in his bedroom like chilling out writing
or typing on camera what he's doing and
it was dave is that the part that
matters the most
no no they play 24/7 low but what's
lo-fi well lo-fi hip-hop is like amateur
it's you know amateur made mixes you
know we're talking like SoundCloud type
music here but it's all about the same
BPM it's laid-back and it kind of just
effortlessly flows from one thing to the
next and it's actually become like my
go-to writing music over the past couple
of weeks has it looped have you heard
stuff again and he knows I have it I
don't know I don't know where the end is
and if it did loop it's the kind of
thing I would even so dream it's not a
video may not be it's so and again I
don't know who's making this music I
don't know how they're making money I
don't understand the business model I
mean they've got like a link to their
website in the description of the video
and I guess you can go there and do
something I don't understand the
business model at all all I know is that
I'm just consuming just high volumes of
music in a way that it's effortless
ultimately what I'm getting at is
whether it's walking home walking into
my house and hearing my kids stream the
latest chance the rapper releases that
he just released or listening to lo-fi
hip hop it's I can get I can get
anywhere and it's and I'm completely
surrounded by it so while I do think
that it's become disposable it's become
so much more prolific at least for me
but this has got to be true everybody
what I use saying is it's become it's
actually become a more valuable mainstay
in your lifestyle as a whole like it can
it can all because it can always be
there as a constant companion I mean
that's valuable so I don't any but at
the same time it could make it all seem
more disposable because well I don't
it's not it's not an object it's not
something that I got a pour-over like
the liner notes or anything like that
well especially that so because there is
something to be said for and this is
some people's philosophy for my
philosophy once I started streaming was
because I heard people say well I pay
for streaming but if I really
I can artists I buy their album it's
like well once you're like once you
could just add the music locally to your
devices it just became a loyalty issue
at that point it's like am I really
gonna give this artist 12 bucks just
because I really like them I mean yes
some people will do that that's it
that's not a sustainable business model
but I think that what you could do what
a lot of people do is they say well I I
do want to buy this physical thing and
this is kind of like the analog
revolution that's happening right so
it's well under way the vinyl the Anaka
sets are coming back and I think that's
because ultimately we haven't changed
you know physically mentally the the
Hardware of humanity is the same as it
has been for thousands of years and so
we're tactile beings right we experience
things with all the senses so the fact
that while we kind of moved into this
completely digital place where you think
oh well just like the in the dead iPod
song we kind of talked about in the
distant future people are just gonna
download songs directly into their brain
that's I don't that might happen but
ultimately unless we change
significantly physically we're not gonna
lose that desire to have a tactile
experience you're never gonna lose an
appreciation for a piece of music that
is on something physical like if I hand
you I mean you just got a record player
if I if I if I and I bought you a bunch
of crazy albums but if I gave you an
album that you didn't have but meant
something to me your experience with
that your there's nothing you can do in
the digital world that can top that and
that's why people are that's why people
are kind of right rebound back to it
yeah I'm definitely I have a desire to
the albums that have been the most
important in my life I have a desire to
buy them on vinyl just to own just to
have that habit just to literally have
it I don't think everybody has to do
that but I I think the the other thing
that I try to do I that I'll go so far
as to encourage people to do is to adopt
the discipline of
immersing yourself in music and making
time making focus time for that if
you're a music lover go don't Rob
yourself the experience of going all the
way I'm not trying to make this sexual
but but I just I mean I some nights I'll
lay in bed with my with my headphones
and go all the way with your headphones
on I typically wear my ear pods when I
do that and I'll listen to music and and
I'll just I'll focus on it so it's not a
companion to anything it is it is the
object of my affection at that moment
and my analyzation right and I'll go one
step further I I love doing that within
the context of an album you know I think
with with this wide experience it's a
single focused as opposed to an album
oriented world that we now live in but I
think there are artists who are still
crafting albums and like like Kendrick
Lamar I mean if you you can listen I
mean you can listen to don't kill my
vibe and that's good that's a great song
but if you listen to good kid maad city
as a whole then you've immersed yourself
in a cinematic experience that an
amazing artist crafted he made an audio
movie and it's you how you got to listen
to all of it to get that and I mean it's
your loss or mine if we if we don't do
that but it but it now takes a
discipline that we were that we were
trained to expect from certain artists
and we would we were trained to expect
from from more artists actually you got
to sit here and you got a press play and
then you got to flip it over at a
certain point and yeah you see what I'm
saying so now it's you we got to
actually you make a decision to take
time to do that
or if you're driving in a car still
saying I'm gonna I recognized this
artist made this album as a cohesive
work and so I'm actually gonna
experience it that way over my next
three commutes well I try to do that I
think both of us are biased against
playlists I mean I yeah yeah I am I mean
we did the mixtape thing it was usually
like mixing one artist like we would mix
merle and you would just be like the
lonesome side and the love inside that
would take all the songs about being
alone which is quite a bit when you're
talking about Merle Haggard and then the
other side would be all the songs about
being in love and I would yeah and I
would in sometimes together we would
just go down a country road and put that
album and put that cassette in and just
sing at the top of our lungs and
sometimes I would just go by myself and
think about the girl that I had a crush
on and was not responding to me and just
listen to her songs but we have kind of
a saw her recently by the way no you did
though yeah and there's that and his axe
piece oh okay well back home we'll talk
about that in a second and of course
lots of girls didn't respond to me so it
could be it could be it could be one of
many different women they were all there
it's like what am i under she all the
women have rejected me into the Zaxby's
that's a recurring but but the why don't
you the we're both in this is to do with
our age I'm sure but I always I'll put a
playlist on or like Pandora or like a
radio like an Apple radio station if
I've got people over and I don't want it
to end you know
but if I'm never never once played one
of the Apple radio stations while in the
car I don't it's just I don't know it's
weird because I would listen to the
radio itself but I find an album I find
an artist and sometimes I feel like if I
listen to an artist and they have one
good song
the rest of the album sucks I just write
them off I don't I don't I don't say I'm
gonna take that song and put it into a
playlist I'd say like no this album
doesn't work so this artist doesn't work
and this is just a this is just an
internal bias that yeah I don't build
playlists I mean for myself because it's
too much work
but if I like an artist like if I really
like Lord Huron I'll go to Lord Huron
radio and then it'll play other artists
I'll discover other people related by
just listening to that around the house
or whatever well so I think for me to
answer that initial question it's
definitely become more disposable I mean
my relationship with music isn't
anything like it was in 1982 in my
bedroom but I the amount of music that
is in my life in different environments
also we didn't talk about that just the
technology just being able to have
multiple devices all around you being
able to listen to music while you run
being able to listen to music while
you're you're working out when you're in
your car and you're making the choice
and you're being intentional about what
you're listening to like the combination
of streaming music with the devices that
are available has made music so much
more prolific that I think that probably
like the happy medium is somewhere kind
of what you're doing which is you've got
because I don't I currently don't have
any analog experience with music I got
like a record player but we couldn't
find a place to put it and then I didn't
buy anything for it and then last time I
tried to use it there the needle was
broken so I'm out I don't have an
analogue experience at all and that I I
don't listen to that much takes a lot of
work you know it's I mean when I'm going
to bed you got to lift that record up
you gotta work it out of the sleeve you
know set it on that is it in your
bedroom it's in the living room so it
and it's not it's not hooked up to the
best speakers and I kind of like a
headphone experience I could hook up my
headphones to it what
around with headphones I was like a
Walkman but it was a record player it
would be real steady handed I'll try
I'll try it I'll definitely try it well
let's continue this conversation on the
Internet in the comments below if you're
watching this on Twitter hashtag ear
biscuits we're gonna get involved in
that conversation yeah and if you have a
music lover in your life send them this
episode
tell them they can reminisce along with
us maybe we'll trigger some memories
from them and and and spark a thought of
oh I need to go back and listen to that
album or that song I remember the first
thing I listened to was this so this was
my favorite album when I was in middle
school type thing so thanks for sharing
this episode and for talking with us
like Rhett said using hashtag ear
biscuits we'll bring you another biscuit
next week
[Music]